don't spend money until you're making
money teach yourself that at the
beginning of your venture you are not
going to spend your money
until you're actually making money what
are you going to do you're going to
invest your heart your hustle your
energy your drive your motivation but
you're not investing your money until
you're making money people say well
don't you need money to make money like
no you don't need you don't need money
to make money you need your energy you
need your resourcefulness as soon as you
focus on resources as being the problem
you've lost
it's never a lack of resources it's a
lack of resourcefulness
it's you feeling that it's a lack of
resources that is the problem and that
prevents action that prevents forward
motion because you feel hey if i only
had x amount of money then i would be
able to do this
there's always a way to start smaller
there's always today you could do
something today some small step today to
move one little step closer towards
achieving your goals
and it's that inaction due to a lack of
resources or perceived lack of resources
that prevents people from actually
accomplishing their goals and reaching
their their mission that that's what
happens so there's always a there's
always a smaller way to get started and
to teach yourself especially the
beginning
that you want to be more resourceful
that you don't want to spend your money
until you're making money so instead of
focusing on how you can spend money that
you don't have think about how can you
do something with what you do have
and to invest your heart your energy
your time your hustle your drive but not
your money
until you're making money
[Music]
so so how do you do it what you know
what what are some of the steps well
step one is you dream big but you act
small dream big act small there's
there's the big mission you've got is
amazing that's what's going to fuel you
you don't want to feel like every day
you're waking up and doing something
small
you've got this big drive this big
ambition it's awesome
and
act small
like today do something
instead of waiting for venture capital
or somebody put you on or to co-sign you
just do something
dream big act small need motivation
watch a top 10 with believe nation top
woman and 10. and men
hey it's evan carmichael and i make
these videos because chances are you
are the most ambitious person in your
circle but you know you're capable of
more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
evan carmichael and our take on his top
10 rules for success
enjoy
[Music]
rule number two
take control of your thoughts most of us
never take control of our self-talk you
don't
take control of the thoughts that you
have about yourself when you're by
yourself it doesn't even matter as much
what our parents think what our friends
think what our husband or wife thinks
it's you
you're the problem you think negatively
about yourself you are not consistently
filling yourself with thoughts with
positivity with ambition with courage
the default pattern is one of mediocrity
of one of i can't do this one of lack of
resourcefulness and so that's what you
live
and it's possible to change
and in making that shift and making that
change you become
an entirely different person we talk
about
how to become the best version of
yourself how do you live your life how
do you how do you show up as that proud
version this is it
it's taking control of the automatic
self-talk that you have to yourself even
if you don't actually talk to yourself
even if you're not saying
evan you're an idiot right evan you
can't do that even if you're not saying
those things out loud you're feeling
those things
it's at a subconscious level
and this is where you're playing small
and they've been limiting yourself i
am afraid a lot
i'm afraid a lot and i used to let that
fear dominate me i used to let that fear
prevent me from doing the thing that i
needed to do whether it's making videos
whether it's speaking on stage whether
it's interviewing people
i don't believe in being fearless i
think if you're fearless it means that
you are just doing the things that are
inside your comfort zone you're
photocopying your life i think if you're
fearless you actually hate your life
because you're just doing things that
you know how to do i think fear is a
great thing
it's not being fearless it's having the
fear and then showing up because of not
even the spite of because of because
you're afraid then you have to go do the
thing
because you're worried then you have to
go do the thing because you're
afraid of somebody's judgment and you
have to go to just because just to teach
yourself that you do it so
for me speaking on stage
doing interviews
making videos were the three that i
struggled with the most this guy who's
made 10 000 videos has spoken in front
of thousands of people have done
interviews with some of the biggest
people on the planet i'm still afraid
every time
i'm still afraid every time
and i don't let that fear now stop me
from doing the thing
i'm still you know i had tony robbins on
my channel uh and i had him on three
years or two years before
but i'm still nervous to have him on my
heart's still beating my crazy i'm still
an emotional wreck the day of i'm still
not focused
on anything else i can't do any other
work i can't make any other videos
because i'm i'm stressed about the
interview going well i still worry about
these things it doesn't go away there's
just levels to this
and i still want to show up
where old evan younger evan used to
find a reason why i couldn't do it
final reason why i couldn't show up
live in the fear and justify it as an
actual reason or excuse but deep down i
was just afraid think about your reasons
like why can't you do this thing what
are you telling yourself that you can't
do really deep down it's just a fear
you're just afraid
there's no really good reason you've
convinced yourself there's a reason but
deep down you're just afraid
right if you're actually honest with
yourself you're just afraid rule number
three
don't live in regret living and regret
sucks
imagine you are 95 years old you're
looking back on your life at this moment
on this day
realizing that you could have played
bigger you could have done more you had
more potential you had an opportunity in
front of you you could have done
something and you didn't you didn't
because you were afraid you came up with
some some reason that you actually
believed that was really an excuse you
played small you didn't accomplish your
goals now you're 95 years old and it's
over and you can't do it you're not
physically or mentally able to actually
do it
the more you can actually feel that
that that today matters that you want to
stop living your life by other people's
opinions and stop living with the fear
of regret
stop having that thing hang over your
head that you could have done something
and you were too afraid to do it the
more you can actually feel that it can
push you to actually take an action
because otherwise you live the life that
every everybody lives that most people
live most people regret their life most
people
regret not the things that they did but
the things that they didn't do regret
the ideas that you had then you saw
somebody else make a ton of money off of
you regret the conversation that you
wanted to take but you are too afraid to
go introduce yourself like we live in
this
zone of regret already you can feel it
look back to things that happened last
year two years ago or five years ago
like you wish that you
showed up a certain way you wish that
you had more courage more boldness and
you didn't do it you didn't do it and
the point isn't to beat yourself up over
that the point is to use that as courage
to go do something today towards
accomplishing your goals
i used to use the fear of regret a lot
when i was when i was younger especially
to get myself to take action
the biggest decision of all the hardest
decision of all was to
when i was 19 not take the 100k a year
dream job that i thought i wanted to go
become an entrepreneur make 300 bucks a
month own 30 of a company that was the
hardest thing ever and the thing that
gave me the courage to do it was the
fear of regret
and jeff bezos has a great uh regret
minimization framework he calls it where
basically he tries to project out to
being you know that old old old old old
man and living life with as few regrets
as possible so i asked myself what will
i regret more
will i regret more say no to my dream
job
and making six figures and traveling
around the world or will they regret
more say no to this business
and just not knowing
and i thought you know what i can always
go get another job
it may not be the same job it may not be
the same company it may not be the same
opportunity may not be as much money may
not be as much travel may not be this
perfect job but i could get another
similar job i felt like i could get
another similar job this
business idea
this business opportunity i didn't know
that i would ever have this chance again
and so i said you know what even if the
most likely outcome is failure
i didn't think it was going to blow up i
didn't know that it was going to work
out or not even if the most likely
scenario is failure i still have to do
it
because i don't want to live with regret
and i told myself i would rather know
and fail than not know rule number four
show empathy the number one way to deal
with negative people in your life is
through empathy
it's empathy it's not it's not hating
them back it's not spreading negativity
it's not reminding yourself that you're
better than them it's it's empathy
and it's not even just feeling bad for
them
it's actually connecting to them
let me let me explain
i default to this human the people are
good
this is a wild idea
people are good humans are good i've
done the who exercise the year one word
exercise helping people find the most
important core value with so many people
and
it's always something positive
i believe that 99.9999999
of people are good there's a tiny tiny
tiny percentage of people who enjoy
killing people and maybe have you know a
few screws loose up here but for the
most part we're good everybody has
dreams everybody has ambitions everybody
wants to serve everybody wants to be in
a better place than where they are right
now
the problem is
a lot of people are afraid a lot of
people are in pain a lot of people are
struggling a lot of people are suffering
a lot of people have tried they took
their shot and it didn't work out and
because they're so
in pain now they don't want other people
around them to have success either
because if they took a shot and it
didn't work out
it's they don't want to own it that it's
on them but if you then go off and have
success you start achieving your goals
what does that say about them
right it's not that the world is rigged
against them it's that they actually
suck and they don't want to admit that
they don't want to own up to that and so
they're living in pain and so they take
it out and other people they take it out
anew they take it out on me they take it
out on on the world they take it out on
people right that's what that's what
people do when they're in a lot of pain
think about you think about your
experiences your life think about when
you've been in a lot of pain when you've
struggled really think about this the
last time that you were struggling a lot
of pain did you then show up as your
best self in all situations
did you maybe lose your cool on somebody
did you maybe
insult somebody did you maybe say
something that you're not proud of that
you later would regret has it has that
ever happened to you
so that you're a bad person it's not
that you're a toxic person it's not that
you're a hater
you were just in a lot of pain
and so the people who are throwing shade
at you are in a lot of pain they're
struggling
and just recognizing that just trying to
put yourself in their shoes and look at
their life
and if you know them you can actually
look at their life and if you don't know
them you can assume things about their
life
if somebody's coming to leave in a
negative comment on your youtube video
the fact that that is the highlight of
their day speaks volumes about them
right if the best part of your day is
going to somebody's youtube channel
leaving some nasty comment that gets you
feeling good
you're in a lot of just imagine the pain
that that person's in imagine what their
life is like right now
and it's a bit of a mental exercise
because at the beginning
the natural reaction is to be defensive
like well no i'm not this and how could
you call me that
and
we want the people around to support us
and cheer us on and tell us that we're
doing the right thing so the natural
defense mechanism kicks in where we say
no i'm that's not that's not right but
if you take a breather you can take a
step back and you can just
try to have empathy try to put yourself
in their shoes try to see that they're
in a lot of pain
what it does is removes the sting from
the words it removes the venom from the
words
it doesn't get you to react
as emotionally it allows you to show up
more as your best self
it's it's one of the most valuable
things you can start to practice this is
one of the things that prevents people
from creating content from posting
videos from sharing their thoughts
you've got a big mission a message your
story can change people's lives you your
story your story can change people's
lives it will change people's lives and
we're afraid to do it because of how
people that we don't know or people that
we do know will judge us
we're afraid that we're going to get
negative comments and that's the reason
why you're not putting your message out
there we have to learn you have to learn
to stop getting in your own way and to
start
sharing
to start releasing to start living your
life the life that you want not somebody
else's version of it also if you want to
have more self-confidence and
self-belief the sign says it can take up
to
254 days of consecutive action for the
habit to stick that's what i want for
you so i've designed a custom free
program we're going to send you an
unlisted video for the next 254 days to
shift your confidence and belief forward
the link to join is in the description
below
if you're doing work that you love
you're more likely to follow through
you're more likely to do it because it
doesn't feel like work because you love
doing it don't worry what the first step
is people write in and say what's my
first it doesn't matter something do
something and then do something again
tomorrow and do something again the next
day and every day you get a little bit
better they're great because they can
help you one
navigate the waters of dealing with
publishers and creating a proposal
that's really going to win because you
might only get one shot with a publisher
so she has a new author and if your
proposal sucks they likely won't want to
look at it again unless you've done
something dramatic on your audience size
to really build up notoriety around
yourself rule number five
follow the right order there's an order
to things it's a sequence to things
part of the problem with a lot of
entrepreneurs is they're just not doing
the things in the right order
you're trying to tackle that big mission
from the start
doing all 30 things at the same time
and not making any money and not making
any momentum not making any progress and
ultimately not having the impact that
you want to have
so out of your 30 ideas all inside your
mission amazing which one is actually
going to start getting you paid
because when you can start making money
everything becomes
better everything becomes easier you can
quit your job you can pay your bills you
can hire a team you can have a bigger
impact right
if you had a team of 10 people versus
you doing things part time on the
weekends and evenings
you're just going to have a much bigger
impact if you have you working full time
and a team around you how do you get
there what's the one idea of the 30.
rule number six
catch the pattern catching that pattern
it's like oh it happened again again
again i wanted to go and do this and i
didn't do it again i had this
opportunity to talk to somebody and i
played small again i had this chance and
i didn't do it and you're gonna catch it
a day later a couple days later and
reflect back on it and realize okay i
should have done it next time i'm gonna
try to have more awareness
step one is just the awareness game
because it's the problem is it's
it's so autopilot we play small by
default
especially we've been doing it for
decades you play small by default so
it's so ingrained so natural so
autopilot that we have to slowly shift
out of autopilot zone eventually what's
going to happen is you're going to catch
it
in less than a day you're going to catch
it a couple hours later they're going to
catch it
an hour later they're going to catch it
10 minutes later they're going to catch
it five minutes later and then step
number two is you're gonna get to this
magical moment you're gonna get to this
magical moment where it's about to
happen you've caught it you've caught
your small thinking you've caught your
scared thinking you've caught your
excuses thinking
in the actual moment that it's happening
this is a magical spot right now
because
you're actually calling yourself out on
your own bs right now
and what you need to do is get enough
courage to actually take the action to
pivot courses to instead of doing what
you historically normally would do on
autopilot now we're going to take the
other action the action where you're
proud of yourself the action that you
don't want to live and regret
that version of you showing up rule
number seven
spend time with yourself spend a little
time with yourself
and and finish the sentence i am what i
am blank i am blank what's the blank you
are what if you're just by yourself you
have a little space to breathe from your
environment you are what what are some
of the words that come up what are some
of the positive words what are some of
the negative words that show up if
you're being honest with yourself
there'll be hopefully some positive ones
so
um for me it could be i'm someone who
believes i am
uh
i am a great husband
so i'm paying attention i am you know a
great father i am a
great
not owner what do you do with dogs i
don't know like great you're still
consider your kids they're my kids yeah
dark kids package
all right
you know i am i bet that on the negative
side like i am
uh
afraid of disappointing people i am
scared of speaking on stages i'm worried
that i'm gonna
ask bad interview questions like what
are the positive and negatives if you
feel in the i am okay just to get
awareness of yourself this starts to
uncover some of the subconscious
behavior that you're living on autopilot
right the subconscious is the autopilot
it's what you're doing by default the
conscious of what we want to
take control of to then turn into
subconscious to then make
the automatic
the positive the ambitious the bold the
courageous right so start with i am what
that does is
lead you to step two which allows you to
identify your trigger words so
what are the trigger words that you use
consistently as an excuse for you not to
do the thing so my three trigger words
are scary difficult or hard that when i
say
scary
difficult hard
those used to be the reasons why i
couldn't do something those used to be
the reasons why i would let myself off
the hook those used to be the things
that would tell myself oh i can't do
this because it's scary i can't do this
because it's difficult i won't show up
because it's hard
and i would let myself off the hook for
those things that i would say oh that's
okay because it's scary so i'm not gonna
do it
and and i would that would used to be my
identity rule number eight
swim forever you wanna swim forever
adopt the mindset that you want to swim
forever most people if you're thinking
about swimming
you're swimming to reach the island
right if you're swimming in the ocean
you're swimming to reach the island
the island is is some gold the island is
i want to hit a million subscribers i
want a million revenue or
whatever some arbitrary goal
the goal isn't to hit the island
your intention shouldn't be to hit the
island it should be to swim
you have to love swimming you want to
swim forever i want to swim forever
every now and then you might need to
look back
you know and see how far you've come
see how far you swam every now and then
we need that
that mindset that that
that gratitude that perspective to say
wow i'm i'm so much further ahead than i
used to be right a big challenge with
achievers is we don't feel like we've
done enough
especially high achievers you don't feel
like you've done enough
and and that can often be a drive
forward but sometimes it's so
overwhelming that it actually puts you
in a negative state where where prevents
growth
so in those moments you look back and
say how far you swam like wow i've come
a long way
to break to who i used to be
the the
accomplishments the belief systems the
mindset the relationships like
the personal development how much have
you grown if you actually think about it
how much have you grown in the past five
years is probably crazy if you're a fan
of this channel you're watching this
video you've grown a lot in the past
five years and every now and then when
you're feeling low you need that
perspective shift to look back and see
how far you've come but otherwise it's
forward
growth more growth you want to swim
forever you don't want to hit the island
you want to swim forever
we've all experienced those moments
where you you hit a goal
and then and then what what what do you
feel you feel a moment of happiness of
of accomplishment and then like oh is
that
is that all there is
you know when i hit a million
subscribers on youtube like that was the
drive that was the goal i want to hit a
million subscribers on youtube
i wanted to hit it
i don't even remember what the goal i
wanted to hit it before gary
i wanted to hit a million subscribers
for garyvee and we did it
and they're like oh i'm still the same
person
somehow we feel
that
when we
accomplish something we're going to feel
different we're going to be different
you're going to be a different person
when you hit that goal
and it it we end up getting confused
because it's not even about the goal you
become a different person in the pursuit
of the goal
i've studied more successful people than
most people just in the nature of the
work that i do and there's a reason why
the number one rule of success over and
over and over and over and over and over
and over again is you have to love what
you do you have to love the process
successful people they love the process
they love the doing they love the actual
showing up every day
i'm sitting here at a at a
nina's inside there can we see
nina's inside at a at a tnt it's a
chinese grocery store she's inside doing
shopping i'm sitting here in the car
making videos why because i like it i
like i like the process i like it's not
about how many subscribers i have on the
channel i like feeling like this matters
that you i'm so grateful that you're
thank you honestly thank you for
watching this video i'm so grateful that
you're here watching this video that i
could make something from my car that's
worthy of somebody else's attention
thank you
i love this
we've done over 10 000 videos
why because i love it like if it's just
a strategy if you're just trying to
reach the island you drown
if you're just trying to reach the
island you drown you have to love
swimming
this is the mistake most entrepreneurs
make when they're first getting started
is you're just chasing an opportunity
but you don't actually love the process
this is a great
uh quote one of my favorite quotes of
all time it's an african saying that
beyond the mountain is more mountains
and it's similar to the swimming analogy
beyond the mountain there's more
mountains what do you do when you get to
the top of the mountain there's another
mountain to climb you don't you don't
ever want to get to the top of the
mountain think about if you if you hit
the top
you're going to start to hate your life
because there's no growth because we
want more growth we want more learning
we want more progression
if you felt like you hit the top that's
the fast path down to depression beyond
the mountain is more mountains
it's the greatest quote of all time at
least one of them i love that one i
think a ted turner's father whose goal
was to be a millionaire and then he hit
the million and
he killed himself
because he thought you know he wasn't
happy with his life he wasn't happy with
his his process he wasn't happy with
what we're doing every day but if he hit
a million dollars then everything's
going to change then he's going to be a
different person
he hit his million
and he was the same person
he wasn't happy so he killed himself
so ted turner who's you know a
billionaire one of the wealthiest people
in the world decided i'm going to set a
goal so big that i'm not going to hit it
and that's the point of having a vision
you know a mission like something so big
beyond yourself that you never hit it i
want to solve the world's biggest
problem that people don't believe in
themselves enough
i'm never going to do that it's not it's
not going to happen not in my lifetime
and yet i wake up every day trying to
make that happen in my lifetime
you have to want to swim forever rule
number nine
hold yourself accountable tell the
people around you
so nina nina stepped out but
uh nina my son my team my family
i'll let them know hey if i say scary
difficult or hard i want you to let me
know
if i say
to you in any conversation i can't
because it's scary or it's difficult or
it's hard i need you to call me out on
it
because i'm not gonna i still don't
catch all of them
it's
a lot more than it used to be and i'm
probably i don't know 90 95 percent of
the way there but there'll still be some
small percentage and having people hold
you accountable
is really important
now the default thinking for them is
gonna be what are you talking about you
you're always doing all of these things
you're always
showing up you're always doing scary
difficult hard in in my case
yeah but not like i could be
there's there's another level to this
and everything i want out of life my
mission my my
vision my boldness is on the other side
my great life is on the other side of
even more scary difficult and hard
i have to start living it and so i need
help in catching it
so you use yourself
as step one as the first part but then
if you can
as a bonus bring in
the accountability to the other people
in your life who can help you catch it
and you're not allowed to get angry at
them
you're not allowed to get frustrated
with them
if if you say one of your trigger words
and they say you just said it
you're going to want to say nah but
she's this that doesn't count it doesn't
mean it i was thinking something stop
letting yourself off the hook
and said you say you're right
i need to go do the thing and the more
you can train that
trigger word came up i'm doing the thing
trigger work came up and doing the thing
trigger work him up and do the thing
it's scary i'm doing it it's difficult
i'm doing it's hard i'm doing it just
because you start shifting your identity
you start changing your self-talk
now you start to become the person
that you're proud of you start to become
the person that you you say you want to
be you start to actually become
the person you've become the best
version of you and rule number 10
before some very special bonus clips
inflict pain inflict so much pain on
yourself a future regret that if you
don't do this thing how painful it's
going to be for you how you're going to
regret it your entire life that it
forces you
into action to do the thing
that will make yourself proud that will
build the life you want that will help
create the dream that you know you're
capable of doing now i've got a really
special bonus clip that i think you're
going to enjoy but before that it's time
for the question of the day i want to
know what was your single biggest
takeaway from this video and your plan
of action for the next week the science
says that when you just watch a video
you get motivated to get inspired you
have a 35 chance of following through on
your goals 35 that's not enough that's
not enough just to get motivated believe
nation we're here you're here today
matters you're an action taker
when you commit to a plan of action of
when and how you're going to follow
through when you write it down you have
a 91 chance of following through and
when you commit publicly to somebody
else it jumps to 95 chance from 30
something percent to 95 chance of you
following through believe nation we need
to make this happen so question of the
day your single biggest takeaway from
this video and your plan of action
specific for the next week put it down
in the comments below and i'm going to
show on screen
sometime next week to celebrate
actually look at your life and you enjoy
what you're doing
people ask me do i burn out in what i'm
doing like i don't i don't
i don't burn out i like i like it too
much
like this making these videos i'm gonna
go home after this and
make more videos probably but this video
that i'm making for you right now is not
draining or depleting of my energy it's
contributing to my energy i'm
manufacturing energy by doing this
so that's why it's easy to do
10 000 more videos
because it gives me more than i give to
it
i get more energy as a result of doing
this i'm gonna be a better entrepreneur
better husband a better father
a better boss
a better teammate a better mentor as a
result of making this video
it gives me energy look at your work
that's how you avoid burnout if i was
doing things that that's sap managing if
i was in charge of like washing these
cars i'd be burnt out in in five hours i
would hate my life because i don't enjoy
washing cars i don't enjoy
cars really
so
look at your schedule do a nice audit on
your life how many of the activities
that you're doing every day
are giving you energy versus taking away
energy how many of the people that
you're spending time with are giving you
energy versus taking away energy
and you need to start shifting
from i'm just gonna chase an opportunity
i'm gonna do whatever it takes you won't
hey news flash you won't do whatever it
takes
not if you don't like it but if you
don't love it
you won't do whatever it takes
because you don't love it and that's
okay it's not judging yourself for not
working hard enough just you're not lazy
something you don't want to work hard
you just don't like the thing that
you're doing
this doesn't feel like work to me
so it's getting honest with yourself
it's doing an audit it's looking at your
calendar are you generally excited about
the things you're about to do today and
tomorrow and if not then then we have to
start to shift out of them
right
do the things that give you energy
instead of taking away when you
understand what your single most
important core value is everything else
becomes so much easier so for me it's
belief right believe is my single most
important core value how does that help
well with every decision that i make
it's seen through the lens of belief
every video content that i make is about
belief it has to be every interaction i
have every workshop every book every
meeting all of it has to be run through
the believe
framework right the glasses i believe if
i'm hiring somebody onto my team skills
alone aren't enough it's great that you
can write copies do you believe in
entrepreneurs it's a big difference
so when you understand your core value
everything else becomes clearer and
you're less likely to follow what other
people want you to do everybody around
you they have a goal for you even if
it's well intentioned they have opinions
on what you should do with your life
everybody around you this is what you
should do with your life everybody has
an opinion you don't know which way to
go if you don't know which way to go
it's because you don't know what you
stand for because you're standing on
quicksand but when you understand your
one word your who your most important
core value it's like you're standing on
a rock that nobody can push you from so
how do you figure that out quickly right
i mean this is 200 something pages let's
boil it down super quick for you you
want to think about all the people that
you love
your favorite teacher what you loved
about your parents think about your
favorite musician your favorite band
your favorite song your favorite movie
your favorite book all your favorite
things the thing that when you are
around consuming it reading it being
with them it makes you feel bold alive
amazing confident unstoppable right
we've all had those moments it's just
not consistent enough yet we're gonna
make it for you it's just not consistent
enough yet and so write down a list of
five to ten things that make you come
alive again people your favorite teacher
movies all of those things that make you
that you love that you love like you
could get lost spending time with them
or reading them or listening to them
then write down three key words that
describe each of them
so your favorite teacher why did you
love
mr jones it's not because he taught you
grade four math right there's something
else about mr jones that you love
why do i love seabiscuit the movie
because it's about an oversized jockey
and an undersized horse and an owner
that has no money and all of these
things and they all come together it's
believe right my parents
taught me that i'm evan's really
carmichael i can do anything that i
believe that i can right and so through
all the things that i love believe is
the common thread what is it for you you
have to figure it out you have to figure
it out it doesn't have to take you years
of work just write down all of the
people and the things that you love
three key words for each like do this
this is important just do it today it'll
make a huge difference in your life it's
worth it this is the best 15 minutes you
can spend in your life do it
pause the video and do it and then just
see what comes up consistently what word
comes up over and over and over and over
and over and over again chances are
that's your one word that's your who
then when you discover it you have to
start living that life the reason most
people don't win isn't because you don't
have great ideas you're a genius the
only thing missing is momentum you're
dreaming huge that's amazing i love it
but there is zero momentum it's never
gonna be the right time and nobody is
coming to save you the time is now to
make your dreams happen so here's a
really fun example yesterday i needed to
take a break from my work to go to the
bathroom so i go to the bathroom open up
my feedly and start looking at you know
some of the new stories that were
happening and there was this amazing
video that i saw about a busker in
toronto who
a company organized what they call a
cash mob instead of a flash mob they
would all show up at this guy doing his
you know guitar
singing plane and just throw money at
him not at him but in the guitar case
right and they were they probably made
like a thousand bucks they were throwing
20s and 50s not just pennies and and you
know dollar bills and stuff but giving
him tons of money and and and he's
starting to get overwhelmed he's playing
the guitar he's getting overwhelmed and
and i'm i'm getting motivated and
excited and just heartfelt what a great
moment and i decide in that moment we
need to make this video more public we
need to spread it this has to go up on a
channel i need to spread awareness i
want to i want to promote this company
who put this together i love it what a
great idea
and so right away like here's the thing
you get a great idea trust your great
ideas go do something about it i could
have easily filed that away
next week i'll work on it and then what
guess what's going to happen next week
i'm not going to work on it because i'm
going to move on to something else right
i'm in the middle of my day i've got
priorities and planning for that day
and then this thing pops up
i trust that idea trust that it's great
and that i got to do something about it
because if i'm inspired if you're
inspired you're going to create gold
you're going to create magic
if you're not inspired then just keep
doing the work that you're doing
hopefully it's not depressing and
negative it's just you're creating it's
amazing you're in your flow but when
something new comes up that you're super
excited about i think you need to follow
that through and so i i parked a little
chunk of my day yesterday to then make
that video and i made the ending and i
made the thumbnail and i made the
description and i made the title and i
created it all in one shot and i sent it
off to my editor christina we love you
christina say hey we gotta put this up
on the channel find the time this is not
scheduled in my usual content calendar
but let's find a time put it up right
and that maybe took i don't know half an
hour
it took half an hour out of my day that
i was supposed to do other stuff to make
that happen because momentum matters
momentum matters it's the most important
thing you're a genius the ideas you have
are gold they're genius you're just not
doing enough with it success is the
progressive realization of a worthy
ideal what i took away most from that
definition is the word progressive
you want progress you want to learn you
want to keep growing what was once a
challenge for you is now simple and it's
very easy to fall into a routine that
once served you but is now limiting you
the day you stop progressing is the day
that you start to hate your life and it
can be sneaky it could sneak up on you
without you even noticing what happened
so i was trying to think of a personal
story to share with you about this and i
realize it's been more than 10 years
since i've actually felt that i felt
that i've stopped progressing
that that i started to hate what i was
doing it's been over 10 years it was it
was basically since i started on youtube
and i'm going to share with you that the
the hacks that i use so that you won't
fall into that rut but what happened for
me 10 years ago was i built my website
right i sold my business i had success i
was speaking around the world i started
building my website
and i built it into a giant platform we
had a hundred thousand plus
pages of content making money from
advertising and i just stopped liking
the business it started to feel like
we're putting out content we're putting
out articles just trying to make money
putting out articles that that
i didn't always believe a hundred
percent in we had a bunch of guest
people writing content right had four or
five thousand authors for the website
and not all of their opinions or views
or mindset or voice
reflected my own
and i just stopped liking the business
it was a successful business making
money building a team i had eight people
i think at that time and i decided you
know what i this isn't
this isn't i'm losing the love for this
i need to try new things
and i started making youtube videos it
was one experiment i probably did a
bunch of different things but youtube
was one experiment that i sucked at but
i loved and i kept coming back to and
and it taught me it taught me a lesson
it taught me that you need to explore
this this is what i tell a lot of people
when they're entrepreneurs i had a woman
melissa who joined me on an ig live the
other day and she's talking about how
she's got a real estate business that's
making her money but she wants to be a
speaker and speaking business is growing
i can't support her fully yet but the
real estate business gives her a lot of
money she said well i like doing both
like well no you don't
right like in five years where do you
want to be you want to still be doing
real estate no no five years i don't
want to be doing that i want to be doing
the speaking thing like great that's
where you need to start spending more of
your time it doesn't mean quit the job
it doesn't mean stop doing real estate
or stop doing the thing that you're just
okay with but while you still have one
foot in it you have to explore you have
to try you have to taste you got to see
what else you can do spend one day a
week two days a week depending on your
financial situation is my advice to her
spend one day or two days a week
focusing on the speaking business so
that in six months you could be out of
the real estate business and being
speaking full-time
and then do anything you love
right if you just like it
that should be a warning sign to get out
not asap but you need to start exploring
but so many people end up hating the
things they're doing so many
entrepreneurs start a business they love
it it's challenging it's exciting it's
exhilarating
and then they found that they bought
themselves a job and they actually hate
their business and then it becomes too
late to get out because you can't find
the person to sell it to or you just
have to walk away from it you don't win
a nobel prize by telling yourself that
you want to win a nobel prize you win a
nobel prize by having a mission so big
that it forces you to become somebody
new a stronger more bold more resilient
version of you if you make success your
goal you will most likely miss it
because you have the wrong outcome in
mind make impact your goal make your
mission your goal and you'll end up
having more success than you ever
thought possible i look at my youtube
channel as an example and
the next goal would be to have 10
million subscribers right i got my
hundred thousand plaque i got three of
them there i got my million plaque
the next goal is 10 million and there's
nothing wrong with having goals but the
problem is if i made 10 million the
thing like all i'm doing is chasing down
10 million subscribers it forces you to
do short term decisions that end up not
serving you right if i wanted to just
blow up my channel the best way to do it
isn't actually to spread positive
content negativity spreads much faster
than positivity if i made a top 10 video
on why this person sucked or an espresso
about how this person is an idiot or
people fighting people can't help but
see that people
that's why people stop to see the car
accident on the highway right we don't
reward the good drivers you want to see
the chaos you want to see what caused
the flame there's a fight on the street
corner you stop to see what's going on
right we're attracted to the negativity
more than the positivity that's a faster
way to blow up my channel the problem is
i wouldn't feel good about it
i don't want to spread negativity i
don't want to spread conflict in chaos i
don't want to spread pessimism i don't
want to spread
despair i don't want to spread ego i
don't want to spend negativity i just i
don't want to do that and so it would
lead to me flaming out before i ever hit
the goal
that's the problem you can have this
goal this is what most people do you
have some goal here's my goal i'm going
to do whatever it takes to get to that
goal the problem is you won't do
whatever it takes because it's going to
get too hard you can only do things for
so long that you don't love before you
quit and give up and so there's nothing
wrong with having a goal but more
important than the goal is the mission i
want to sell the world's biggest problem
it's something that's never going to
happen never in my lifetime it's never
going to happen i want people to believe
in themselves more it's never going to
hit that ultimate goal where everybody
is michael jordan at something it will
never happen and i wake up every day
trying to do that and so if you make a
goal
tied to some outcome like getting 10
million subscribers on youtube it's
gonna force you down a path that likely
won't serve you so you lead with the
mission you leave with the impact and
success will follow the difference in
people is their standards the world is
full of people who started with less
than what you already have right now and
they're winning and too many people are
out there complaining complaining that
you don't have the money that you don't
have the time that you don't have the
experience that you don't have the
personality for it all legitimate
logical reasons but
others have done it with those very same
circumstances as you with worse
circumstances than you the difference is
they have a higher standard for
themselves and today we're gonna raise
yours one of the things i'm most proud
about for myself why do i love evan
carmichael is because when i say i'm
gonna do something i do it especially
when it gets hard like it doesn't count
until it gets hard and i'm doing it not
just for other people i'm doing it and
that's because i promised you that i
would show up i'm doing it for myself
because i said i was going to do
something and then i go off and do it
this is the foundation of self-esteem a
self-confidence of self-love doing it
when you say you're gonna do it and so
on monday i usually have a two-hour
walk-in meeting with alex alex help
someone trying to dance salsa he comes
over monday's my mentoring day and we'll
usually go for a two-hour walk around
the city and it's starting to get cold
you know it's winter time here it's
getting cold and so we bundle up and we
go for our two-hour walk while we while
we talk and while we meet i'm trying to
do walking meetings more just for my own
health and and just because just for the
challenge of it because it's easy to
start something like that in the spring
or in the summer it's really hard to do
it when it's in the winter and you live
in toronto canada and it's snowing and
cold right
so this monday alex was sick
he still came in he was sick he was
running a bit of a fever not crazy sick
but just sick
and nina my wife super karen said hey
maybe you shouldn't go for a walk
outside
and and in my heart just like come on no
we have to i said i was gonna do it
right i have to i have to for myself i
have to go on the walk like i'll go on
the walk and leave alex at my place and
and just film the meeting with him uh
but we came up with a different solution
which was i have a i live in a condo we
have a gym in my condo and we went down
to the condo gym and i walked on the
treadmill while he stood or sat next to
me for two hours because i said that i
was gonna do it
how important is that one two hour walk
not much right in itself not much am i
gonna get healthy from doing that one
walk no am i gonna lose weight by doing
that one walk no i'm gonna have so much
more mental clarity by doing that one
walk of course not
but it's the whole game because you're
teaching yourself that you follow
through you're teaching yourself that
you have high standards you're teaching
yourself that when you say you're gonna
do something you follow through because
life is coming for you with a ton of
roadblocks
life is gonna throw tons of curve balls
at you if you can only do the thing that
you said you were gonna do when it's
easy and the path is perfectly clear
you're never gonna do it this is why
people don't stay consistent because as
soon as life gets hard
you let yourself off the hook
you allow your standards to drop to say
oh it's okay yeah of course i can't go
for a walk cause alex is sick
right and there are definitely
legitimate times when you should let
yourself off the hook if i was dying in
bed with a fever and i couldn't get out
of bed i wouldn't go for the walk that
makes sense don't be stupid there's
times when you need to be gentle on
yourself
but more often than not we are too
gentle on ourselves when we shouldn't be
i could have done the walk and we did it
we did it in the in the in the gym
downstairs and alex stood next to me and
sat next to me and didn't have to go
outside and and get the cold on him and
i still got my walk-in right and i feel
great about it
because i did it when it was hard
because here's this obstacle that life's
thrown at me here's an easy way when
everybody around me saying you don't
have to go off and do it and a little
tiny voice inside my own head saying
okay well here's a chance you don't have
to do it like no
be quiet voice i'm doing it we're
finding a solution let's go
and the solution is going to walk on the
treadmill downstairs what matters is
that you're productive that you get
results that you stop wasting time too
many people default to thinking that if
they just wake up an hour earlier
they're going to be way more productive
if you're not productive in a 16-hour
day what makes you think that you're
going to be more productive in a 17-hour
day when you have less sleep so this is
a
interesting message in timing for me
right now because
i i love beating the sun up i love it i
i love working i like it's my default
state if nina is off on a friday night
with her friends or something 80 chance
i'm working i love it i look forward to
it when i go close my eyes i can't wait
for it to be the next day like i'm
pumped to go off and do the work
i recently did a sleep study
and my doctor was concerned i wasn't
getting enough quality sleep so i went
to go do a sleep study and the doctor
after going through the results uh told
me that i need to be sleeping eight and
a half hours to nine hours a night
and it and it like
super disappointed me eight and a half
hours to nine hours are you kidding me
i'm trying to go from i was trying to go
from eight to seven i was waking up
after eight hours sleep and and feeling
still a little bit tired and so that's
why my doctor recommended even going to
the sleep study and i'm trying to figure
out how do i hack it to get down to
seven and still be fully functional not
not be you know
lazy and slow and not having my
cognition
and uh yeah he said i need to be
sleeping eight and a half to nine hours
a night he said is that is that normal
like are you not worried like no as long
as you're under 10 it's normal people
range from six to ten and they're
totally fine like this sucks i mean i'm
not happy about it i'm still looking at
how can i hack my sleep more and we've
tried a lot i have the chili pad we've
got you know meditation before sleeping
i'm lying on the bed of nails with the
thing behind me the pillow the nail
pillow uh
no
you know phones or computers x amount of
time before going to bed red light
filters on everything red lights no
lights at all in the place right like
just these real red lights going around
after sunrise after sunset
lots of it cool down the temperature i
don't know all of it don't eat past
eight o'clock no caffeine past two
o'clock all of it i'm doing all of that
stuff all of it right plus probably a
lot more stuff
i've i've studied and hacked away i
still believe there's a lot more hacking
i still want to get it from nine to
seven but but if i'm at nine and i need
nine i think you should get nine i'm at
the point now where if i wake up and the
sun is still
uh not up i stay in bed
and and that's actually uh boosting of
confidence it's like okay so i wake up
and sun hasn't come up yet okay this is
hard this is difficult it's difficult
for me to not get out of bed i'm gonna
stay in bed just because now i'm i'm a
weird duck
so maybe this works for you maybe it
doesn't but i was having a great
conversation with uh jeremy who's on my
team who
i've invested in his business he's
helping companies scale their youtube
channels and he was going through the
same thing where he was feeling a little
tired in the afternoon he wanted to nap
on some afternoons and that's never been
me so dude you need to just try
uh waking up without an alarm
and he normally he's up at 4 30 in the
morning or something
so just wake up without an alarm and see
how it goes and he ended up sleeping for
nine hours and hated hating himself for
doing it it's like dude maybe you need
nine hours like much more important than
that extra hour or two is what are you
doing during the day if if you're losing
energy during the day and you want to
nap every afternoon you're not being
productive like there's no way
sleep and be productive you need sleep
to win i think everybody should get a
sleep test i think it's a brutal
experience
you don't you barely sleep right when
you're there you've got stuff up your
nose and a million sensors all over you
but to know how much sleep you actually
need uh and making sure that you're
productive during the time that you are
awake that's the most important thing
that you are productive during the time
that you are awake is way more important
than if you wake up before the sun gets
up if you are doing something new you
are going to get rejected if you're
doing something that you're not good at
yet you're going to get rejected if
you're doing something that goes against
the status quo
you are going to get rejected so you
have two choices live a life with zero
growth and never get rejected or chase
your dream
deal with the rejection that comes and
go change the world i have rejection all
the time in my life from little
rejections of making videos that don't
pop to bigger rejections of projects
that i care deeply about that just don't
fly and people don't accept at the
beginning i look i look at this built to
serve this is a great example built to
serve is my new book coming out if you
want to pre-order it in the description
there's a link go get it tons of bonuses
looking forward to it this book
i'm insanely proud of
i think it's life-changing i mean it
should be i think the work that you
create should be life-changing but i
poured so much into this and i think
people need to read it like i i
desperately think that this book
will change a lot of people's lives it
could change your life i believe it's
not just hyperbole like i i truly
fundamentally believe it
when i came up with the idea
i was on my tour earlier this year and
i did not have time to write it right i
was on my tour i'm behind on everything
a million things being thrown at me
meeting people doing my events seeing
the cities and it just i just decided i
have to write this book because of all
the feedback i was getting from people
it was all the one-on-ones i was doing
with people the same questions kept
coming up how do i find my purpose how
do i know who i am how do i turn into a
business and so that's the that's the
point of the book figuring out what your
purpose is and how to use that to then
serve the world right it's called built
to serve
and make it into a business so you can
make money doing it and build a team and
go off and live your mission when i
first pitched my publisher on it they
didn't want it
they didn't want my book right so
your one word is down here that's with
penguin random house and penguin passed
so they had first my first deal with uh
penguin random house
typically how they'll do deals
especially with first-time authors is
you get you get a deal and then they
have the right of first refusal in your
next book so as soon as i get my next
book
they get the right to look at it first
before i give it to anybody else right
so that's why i sign so like okay here
we go let's go it's a perfect fit
i mean it follows really nicely with
your one word
let's go right
and they said uh no we're gonna pass
like yeah what how do you this is better
than your one word i mean i love your
one word it's great
but this is this is this is the whole
thing
how do you pass on this um it's just
and we had to wait because it's 30 days
and all these anyway legal stuff um so
then we started looking at other
companies we started looking at other
publishing houses and there were other
ones that seemed to line up really well
with the content that they had the the
the author lineup that they had
and
almost everybody everybody except the
last one right uh said no
and i mean like i got a i got a big
youtube channel we have momentum we
already have our first book we're like
why
and all sorts of different reasons you
know um just not not doing personal
development books anymore not whatever
uh nobody came out and said like we hate
you evan so maybe hopefully that's not
the reason um
and then we found one that that picked
it up was like okay
let's go
and if if that one didn't pick it up
then then we would have kept looking for
more publishers or i would have just
made it myself just self-publishing put
it out right
what do you do when the people around
you don't accept what you have when you
want to take something in a new
direction i could have done something
else i could have done something easier
if i just did a book about jack ma
right in his real success that would be
easier to pick up than this which i talk
about on the channel but it's not the
main thesis of the channel
but that's what i want to make and
that's what i'm going to make whether
it's i get a publisher or we're going to
you know create it myself it's going to
be birthed into existence because i
decided so and just taking that mindset
and approach you have to
if you love the thing if you're doing
something different
then you have to keep going when people
say that i don't want to pick it up that
it sucks that it's stupid that you're
maybe it's even a great idea but you're
not the person who's gonna do it
right you have to keep going i think
judging yourself is actually great i
think you need it i think it's healthy i
think people should be harder on
themselves the problem is people can't
handle being even a little bit harder on
themselves because they're already at
the point of being depressed or even
suicidal the secret starts with
self-love your self-love has to equal
your self-criticism you have to be your
biggest fan as well as your biggest
critic the root problem isn't judging
yourself it's not loving yourself one of
the challenges to think of being human
is we are social animals we're social
creatures we rely on each other we need
each other we want to belong we want to
be part of tribes we want to do things
together right we want to be around
other people
so that makes us want to fit in and that
makes us
play small
worry about what people think about us
because if we don't do the thing that
they want us to do they might judge us
and kick us out of the tribe the good
news is there's so many different tribes
you can do now right there's so many
different people that it may not be your
friends that you have right now may not
be your parents or your family or your
community right now but whatever you
want to do there is a group of people
who believe the same things you believe
who think the same way you think and i
think one of the healthiest things that
you can do is whenever you feel the eyes
of potential judgment
for something that you want to do you
have to go off into it just to show
yourself comparison to other people i
think is actually a good thing i think
you need it i think it helps you i think
it serves you the problem is most people
look at other people start feeling
insecure and then kick themselves down
the key
is to kick yourself forward
not down
but you need that kick otherwise you
stay where you are this is one of the
reasons why i love modern success why i
created all my youtube channels and all
the content that i've done and have the
people behind me on the wall because i
love looking at other people i love
learning from other people i love seeing
somebody do amazing things and say
that's what's possible
this is what's possible i look at les
brown as an example and i think he's the
greatest speaker of all time at least
that i've i've seen i don't maybe maybe
the ancient greeks were better i don't
know but but les brown modern era on
video i think is the greatest speaker
and
i look at that and say that's what's
possible not that i can't do that here's
what most people do they look at les
brown and say well i can't do that
and then they start feeling insecure and
i'm just i'm just an imposter trying to
be like that now and then they quit
and then they feel they feel low
self-esteem when they and they beat
themselves up over because they're not
les brown
i look at les brown and say that's
what's possible this is what this is
what humans can actually accomplish and
achieve i want some of that i want to
get better i want to drive and improve
not to be the next less brown but be the
best me but this is what's possible i
look at david goggins
man david goggins look he came out of
nowhere who was david goggins did you
guys know david goggins five years ago
no he blew up out of nowhere because of
the passion and intensity and truth of
his message right i love that and it's
easy to say and look at that say well
look at how passionate david goggins is
and look how he blew up i can never do
that
i'm not as strong as him i'm not as
crazy as him i don't have the same
mindset as him and so i can't do that
and you compare yourself to goggins and
then you say well i can't i can't and so
you don't start that's the problem
you should look at goggles and say look
at what's possible
you could come from nowhere nobody
knowing who you are
and in a short amount of time blow up
because you have a message that matters
you can look at how passionate he is
about his message every video he's got
insane passion right this guy he's not
gonna give you nice hugs and compliments
but he he cares about his message right
you can see that and you could take that
as as what's possible you can you can
care deeply about your message too and
model david goggins and and apply that
to make your message stronger and better
i think if you just were competing with
yourself i think you're actually going
to suck i think i think if you're the
best at something and you don't have any
competition i think you actually suck
being the big fish in a small pond
actually limits a lot of creativity
limits your ability to go off and crush
things i think i think it is i think
when you even even in animals when you
see animals going up against each other
in a race
when when somebody's close you work a
little bit harder right i think i think
we need that in our ecosystem the key
though again is to make sure you're
kicking yourself forward to say this is
what is possible not this person's so
much better than me i suck feeling
insecure feeling depressed you need the
kick just make sure you're kicking
yourself forward not down it may not be
your fault but it's your responsibility
it's not your fault that you were born
broke but it's your responsibility to
fix it it's not your fault that you had
no education but it's your
responsibility to learn it it's not your
fault that you had no connections but
it's your responsibility to make them it
may not be your fault but it's your
responsibility and the sooner you accept
that the sooner you're gonna win so i
recently posted to my youtube community
tab a quote about momentum i think
people don't have momentum and i think
the path to get momentum is to do work
for free for ideal clients until you can
prove your value and then they pay you
so here's what i wrote i wrote if you
have no momentum no traction no clients
and start for free prove your worth and
build momentum give them something they
can't wait to have again and pay for
this time hashtag believe
and every time i write there's always
tons of great positive feedback but but
this time somebody
wrote a
kind of negative comment and so i wanted
to read it because it's highly
applicable in this video he said kitsch
i don't know about some of your advice
everything is my fault and work for free
to which i reply yes when you embrace
those two you'll start crushing your
goals
it's a hard message to to take on
right whether everything is your fault
everything's your responsibility where
you are right now it's not about beating
yourself up it's not about saying i suck
and i can't get out saying listen this
is what happened to me that's the past
the past doesn't have to equal to the
future everything that i was born into
and and the circumstances that i grew up
with they don't have to be where i go
going forward look at all your heroes
look at the people who've made huge
inroads change the world the people that
you look up to and aspire to be like
very few of them were born super wealthy
most of them had a worse upbringing than
you did and they could make it so why
can't you
you're just locked in your story too
many people are locked into their story
they're not taking responsibility you're
not saying this is my my problem to get
out of
i wasn't put here right you've been
drafted into a war that you did not
start you were put here
and you have to survive and then you
have to learn to thrive
and it's that decision
that you are in charge that you're
responsible that if you go to the mirror
and you say why am i not achieving my
goals why am i not further ahead
as long as you're blaming somebody else
that might keep you comfortable
it keeps you comfortable it means you
don't have to do anything right you're
not winning because your mom you know
hit you you're not winning because your
dad never supported you right you're not
winning because the school system sucks
as long as it's somebody else to blame
it's it's comforting
and everybody else around us are doing
the same thing nobody's taking
accountability everybody's saying it's
somebody else's fault right of course
it's not your fault that you're losing
because then you have to do something
about it and even if you're not losing
you're not hitting the goals as hard as
you should
and it's so much easier to put the blame
on somebody else and say well
it's that person's fault
well really it's the person in the
mirror it's you it's me
i am not further ahead in my business on
my youtube channel not because of the
youtube algorithm
not because my team didn't deliver the
right video on time me i'm the problem
it's my fault it's my responsibility
right i have to go fix it i created this
mess
it's not a mess is amazing but
i'm not at 10 million subscribers
because of me
it's not that people don't want to watch
the content and people don't want to be
inspired
it's me
i need to get better i need to improve
and and even if it wasn't my fault just
taking that on
gives you hope that you can change it as
soon as you start putting not even the
blame i think blame is not i don't think
blame helps i don't care who's to poo to
blame i care how do we fix it right if
there's a problem that happens in my
business it's not like who screwed up i
don't care who screwed up i care what
are we gonna do to make sure that we can
get out of this hole and then it doesn't
happen again the next time
right taking personal accountability for
where you're at
if you have not hit your goals
there's good news you can
but nobody's coming to save you
nothing's gonna magically change around
you you you're the change you will make
the change you can go make it happen
if i want to grow my business bigger i
need to accept that i need to grow
bigger me personally evan carmichael i
is my fault it's my responsibility i am
to blame
and use that as a kick forward to say
great like at the beginning that may
suck say oh man i've wasted how many you
know weeks months years going down the
wrong path just
casting
blame on other people realizing now it's
my fault okay what can you do about it
now you can change it like at the start
the reality the realization sucks but
then it's also the greatest thing of all
time if you're coming out of
from under the rock and realize oh my
god this is all my fault
that gives you the power to fix it
because as long as you're relying on
somebody else to do something and they
don't show up you can constantly blame
them but you're never growing you never
accomplish anything because you're
waiting for them you have to wait for
anybody
it's just you
and you can fix it you have the strength
you have the power you're michael jordan
you have the abilities you have the
skill set and if you don't have it yet
you can develop it you can acquire it
because your heroes did it and you can
too whatever you want to learn you can
learn public speaking
selling being a youtuber anything if you
want to learn it there is nothing
stopping you except your story because
you tell yourself that you're too young
that you're too old it's too late you're
too broke you don't have the resources
you don't the connections you don't have
the education you don't have the right
family there's always a story you have
not learned the skills that you want and
need because you've told yourself that
you can't and that's the mindset shift
that needs to change now so i recently
made a rap video on my channel
it was a chinese song that i became
obsessed with for some reason i was
looking up chinese music for my wife i
found this one song i loved it it got
stuck in my head and then for whatever
reason i'm lying in bed we go to bed
around 10 30 11 and lyrics just start
popping to my head i don't understand
what the chinese song is about but
lyrics start popping to my head about a
rap so as i come in i start writing it
down i try to go back to sleep more
lyrics come i write it down go back to
sleep i send myself emails because
that's how i get it out of my system
it gets to three something in the
morning 3 30 close to that and like you
know what i'm still getting these ideas
i'm just gonna get up and do it i'm
gonna up and do it i'm gonna get up and
and rap i'm gonna make this rap video
i'm gonna finish off the lyrics and then
i'm gonna spend my day making a rap
video it's not how i want to plan my day
it was not on my calendar i was supposed
to be sleeping but i'm going to wake up
and do this rap
we put all together uh did a whole bunch
of takes sent it to christina to help me
edit it and then the next day boom final
version was up on the main channel now
i don't pretend to have amazing rap
skills right i think the lyrics are fire
i think the song is amazing i think i
think christina did the best she could
with what i gave her and i think the
wrap was pretty good i'm proud of myself
i'm i'm really proud of myself for
in that short amount of time
how good a product i made i'm emotional
i'm i'm committed i'm connected to the
song and i'm yelling
by the end of the song now at the same
time people are leaving comments some
people love it and calling me you know
evan m
instead of eminem some people are
loving it just because it's me and some
people are are nice saying you know what
you're not really a rapper but but good
effort way to put yourself out there
very kind very kind comments
here's the thing
i could be a great rapper
[Music]
i may not be top one percent rapper but
if i practice something
i could be great at it just like you
you could be a great rapper why can't
you be a great rapper
i think the lyrics are fire
i practiced for one day and made a video
and that's what came out if i practiced
every day making rap i could crush it
just like making my youtube videos i
sucked at the beginning i'm a better
rapper now than i was a youtuber at the
very beginning of my career go back and
watch the first video i sucked i was shy
introverted
you know scared of the camera all of it
and so the audacity to believe that i
could be a rapper right doesn't make
sense
how does that make sense just because i
have kanye west on my wall now i can be
a rapper right this is what other people
will tell us and is what you'll tell
yourself i can't be a rapper but why not
you still believe in yourself enough you
can do it just practice
get mentors practice put in the work you
can get great at anything it's a skill
it's just a skill
it's a skill that anybody can learn most
things are just a skill that anybody can
learn
right to make a great cup of coffee i
suck at it but i could pick it up i feel
like i could pick it up it's a skill
anybody can learn there are very few
things very very very few things there's
some things that require
you know a certain amount of athleticism
but spud web could dunk you know there's
a few things right if you are 95 years
old and want to be a quarterback in the
nfl that's probably not going to happen
but we easily jump to those exceptions
meanwhile the thing that you need to
learn
that will help you get to where you want
to go that thing that skill set it's
totally learnable there's no reason why
you can't do it there is no reason why
you can't do it
so i believe i could be a great rapper i
may not win you know a grammy i may not
win awards for it but i could be a great
rapper i could and so can you you could
be a great rapper you could be a great
entrepreneur you can be a great youtuber
you can be a great pianist you can be a
great anything
it's a skill with practice and
repetition and love and execution and
dedication and six thousand attempts
later you can be great at it the single
greatest thing that you can do to
improve the quality of your life is to
take responsibility for it no more
blaming your parents or the country or
the government or your family or your
community or your education no more
blaming other people it's you
it's you
it may not be your fault where you are
right now but it is your responsibility
alone to fix it you didn't pick where
you started but you can choose where you
end up
it's up to you so i remember growing up
my parents were very hardcore in
education you see my parents behind me
here
i'm eight or nine years of my parents
and we were a middle-class family we
weren't poor by any stretch but we also
you know we're not rich
and my parents invested basically
everything they had into our education
they put us all in the private schools
and taking three kids into private
schools was a giant chunk of the income
that they made and so we didn't spend
money on a lot of other stuff you know i
remember driving into my school and all
of my all of the friends all the other
people at the school
had all these fancy cars that when
they're when they turn 16 they're you
know given a mercedes or bmw from their
family and you know my family had a
reliant k car that kind of
made a bunch of noises that as i came
into to the school that was i don't know
how however many years old just because
my family you know prioritized
education and and we were playing in a
league that was
maybe above
our means but they value that so much
and then we took a hit on other things
and i remember used to get made fun of
for the car
and i never went on the vacations that
they went on and i didn't have the fancy
watches and all that other stuff and
there was one friend of mine
who was kind of in a similar boat where
his parents
you know weren't making a lot of money
invested everything that they had into
his education too and so we we quickly
became friends as the uh as i guess the
poor kids
at the school but it's funny now because
i never blame my parents i i'm super
grateful for the opportunities i mean
why i have them up on my wall that they
invested so much and that they cared and
it's on me
like if my business doesn't work out
it's not their fault
right up until you know you can
potentially move out i don't know what
age you want to say if it's 14 15 16 18
but after a certain age you're an adult
i need to take responsibility for your
life the only thing missing in your life
is momentum you're a genius you've got
great ideas you are the michael jordan
of something the only thing that is
stopping you is your ability to do
difficult things and start building
momentum i think for so many people it's
not just doing the thing that scares you
first first thing in the morning it's
doing it at all most people just don't
do it at all you've got a great idea you
know it can work but you're afraid of
judgment you don't know where to start
you're afraid of it being not perfect
and people telling you that you suck and
you failing publicly you're afraid of
all that stuff and so you don't do
anything you got your foot on the gas
and break at the same time knowing that
you're capable of more knowing that you
have greatness in here but then being
too afraid to go off and execute it and
so i think not just starting your day
with the thing that scares you just
moving doing something anything just
getting started on your crazy idea it's
not that you're leaving it to the
afternoon it's that most people aren't
doing it at all so i was on a call with
an entrepreneur friend of mine yesterday
and she was upset she was frustrated she
decided last year
mid last year right june july last year
that she needed to let somebody go on
her team this person was being toxic in
their environment was still producing
results for the company but just being a
big drag on the company on the culture
and on herself as trying to lead this
team of people and so she decided i
gotta let this person go
it's six seven months later now
and she still hasn't done it she still
hasn't done it because she's afraid of
maybe not finding the right person to
replace the impact of having to go
through training and hiring all over
again and she just hasn't made the
decision the biggest problem is she has
not decided and so i said
when is this gonna matter to you you
decided you decided right last year
six seven eight months ago and you still
haven't done the thing and she said well
if it gets to a year and i still haven't
done it then i have to go off and do it
and this is where your standards come
into place
how long after you've made a decision do
you actually start to do something about
it
in her case her standards were a year in
that she decided but then a year later
that's when that's when it's too much
that's when it's gone too far that if
she hasn't done it in a year now it's
too much i want you to shorten that gap
teach yourself that as soon as you
decide you do something you act you put
the plan into motion
because you don't have that many years
left i look at her you know she's she's
not old yet she's not midlife yet but
you don't have that many years left
and this isn't even that big a decision
whatever is in front of you is not
actually that big a decision there are
much bigger decisions ahead it may feel
like a big decision it may feel like it
but after you've done it and you get
through it you'll realize huh i could do
that again and there's another bigger
decision ahead you need to shorten the
gap between deciding that you want to do
something and actually taking action
towards it who you spend time with is
who you become it's why i created this
channel so you and i can hang out with
people like warren buffett you may never
meet warren buffett but you can learn
from him you can be inspired by him and
you can change your life for the better
by consuming this kind of content i love
modeling success because i learned from
bill gates bill gates was the first guy
that i modeled success from i had a
software company was struggling was
making no money i told my partner i quit
and then i asked myself somebody has
done this before i can't be the first
person to try to build a software
company it can't be this hard please
somebody's figured this out and the only
person who came to my mind was bill
gates who started microsoft i hadn't
been really that interested in reading i
hadn't been that interested in studying
success i was just trying to come up
with ideas myself and i was desperate
right i told my partner i quit i was
desperate i was at rock bottom
and so i said somebody's figured this
out i can only think of bill gates at
microsoft and so i studied his company
and how he started the zero to one right
how did he make his first million what
did he do
and it was through partnerships and i
applied that strategy to my business and
and shortly after i had my first deal
for 13 and a half thousand dollars and i
felt like i won the lottery
and after that i had a pattern to use
over and over and over again and since
then it's been 20 years now of sharing
that with you guys it's been for me
constantly learning it's the name of my
channel modeling success it's why i have
all these people behind me on the wall
that's why i make these videos every day
it's why i love learning from people
like warren buffett and steve jobs and
kanye and oprah and all these people
because they can shift you because they
shifted me and the thing that they give
you at least for me they give me one the
inspiration the motivation the idea that
look at what they started with that they
could start from there and end up at
this new place why can't i you you
already have more resources than bill
gates did when he started you have more
resources than kanye did than steve jobs
did when they started you're in a better
position than they were they would have
to create amazing things go study
oprah's story and tell me that you're in
a worse position than oprah was when she
started
you're not
you're not and so it's inspiration the
other part is tactics ideas specific
strategies right bill gates doing
partnerships through distributorships
all of these things learning from that
and saying hey i can apply that to my
business maybe not a hundred percent but
it gets you 80 of the way and instead of
you figuring out the entire solution you
just have to figure out how to bridge
that 20 gap at the end it's much easier
it can link to your success
[Music]
if you want 10 more awesome rules for
success from evan click this video right
over here
continue to believe
and we will see you there until you
actually lean in
on what you have michael jordan ability
genius at until you actually start doing
it
you'll never live the life that you're
capable of